you're watching the daily climate show
on sky news coming up on today's
programme
withdraw funding for a gas project in
mozambique climate scientists write to
the prime minister saying the financing
risks uk leadership on the climate
crisis at high risk of collapse a new
report says coral reefs in the western
indian ocean are now critically
vulnerable
and is this the future of flying as the
government unveils a new zero-emission
hydrogen concept plane will ask if we
can look forward to guilt-free flights
[Music]
hello and welcome to the uk's only daily
climate news show where we track the
changes happening to our world right now
and challenge those coming up with the
solutions
the government must stop over 850
million pounds of funding for a huge gas
project in mozambique so says a letter
from a group of climate scientists
written to the prime minister today
the authors say the funding is
incompatible with climate change targets
tomorrow the decision to fund the
project is being challenged in the
courts by friends of the earth and it
comes towards the end of a year in which
the uk has hosted the world's preeminent
climate summit but has been criticized
for a lack of clear leadership on the
issue of fossil fuels so a year ago
boris johnson announced the uk would end
support for fossil fuel projects abroad
that was a decision that came into force
in march this year now the mozambique
funding decision predated that
announcement
under pressure from environmentalists
ahead of hosting cop26 the government
announced a public inquiry into the
development of a new coal mine in
cumbria
in may the international energy agency
chief said if governments are serious
about the climate crisis there can be no
new investments in oil gas and coal
despite hosting cop26 the uk declined to
join the beyond oil and gas alliance
that's an initiative with the eventual
aim of phasing out fossil fuel
exploration altogether
last week shell withdrew its support for
cambo a proposed north sea oil project
which the government has supported the
company which had a 30 stake cited a
weak economic case
and now investment in the mozambique gas
project is under pressure after a group
of climate experts wrote to the prime
minister asking uk funding to be
withdrawn
well let's talk now to our climate
change reporter victoria seabrook so
victoria how controversial is the uk
funding of this mozambique project well
to a large extent it's incredibly
controversial after all it is the
subject of a judicial review this court
case this week and this group of climate
scientists and experts have written to
the government urging them to withdraw
that money
and part of the reason for this
controversy and the grounds for this
court case is the campaigners who are
bringing the case friends of the earth
they're saying this is not in line with
the paris agreement target of limiting
global warming to 1.5 degrees above
pre-industrial levels and actually in
october sky news revealed that the
emissions from the project the emissions
from the gas when it's eventually burned
um all of that in the climate assessment
was only assessed against two degrees of
warming and not 1.5 degrees which has
broadly globally become accepted as the
much safer threshold that we need to try
and hit and after all the uk government
as host of cop 26 sort of framed that
conference around keeping 1.5 degrees
alive it's also controversial because
that gas could be a significant revenue
stream for mozambique which has been
devastated by cyclone two years ago in
2019
so there's a lot of issues at stake
although the court case specifically is
about compatibility with the paris
agreement target and whether that was
assessed properly
having said all of this the project
hasn't made waves quite quite so widely
and made such big news in the uk
compared with other domestic projects
well yes and there are other legal cases
this week aren't there yes exactly so
there's another court case also in the
high court another judicial review
bought brought by campaigners who are
arguing that the government should stop
what is effectively financial support
for the oil and gas industry and that
support comes in the form of tax breaks
for
aiding exploration of new sites and also
decommissioning of old infrastructure
and their argument is that these
projects would be unviable without that
extra support from the government and
therefore shouldn't go ahead at all if
they're uneconomic and there's a few
other
issues for the government at the moment
related to fossil fuels they're all sort
of slightly different issues there's
also the coal mine in cumbria the
whitehaven coal mine that's the subject
of an inquiry at the moment and all of
these sorts of issues that they're
slightly different but in a sense
they're related because the government
is making big claims about being a
climate leader it's hosted cop 26 and
indeed it has done some very ambitious
things but on the other hand there are
these sort of flies in the ointment and
the campaigners are holding these up to
the government and saying what about
these victoria thanks very much indeed
and just to let you know that later in
the program we're going to be discussing
what role if any natural gas should play
as a transition fuel that's our daily
debate with economist vicki price and
the journalist donica mccarthy
so let's take a look now at some of the
day's other climate news and wildfires
produced a record amount of carbon
emissions in several regions of the
world this year according to climate
scientists from the eu's copernicus
monitoring service fires blazed across
europe siberia and north america
creating the equivalent carbon dioxide
to more than double germany's annual
emissions a copernicus scientist said
increased fire risk is due to drier and
hotter regional conditions under a
changing climate
the uk government has unveiled a design
for a hydrogen-powered plane that could
allow passengers to fly anywhere in the
world with no carbon emissions the
concept plane designed by aerospace
technology institute and funded by the
government would be capable of flying
279 passengers across the world with
just one refueling stop business
secretary quasi quattang described the
design as having the potential to
redefine the future of aerospace and
aviation
and scottish power has projected the
global warming stripes on scotland's
last coal-fired power station
the stripes show the change in global
temperature from 1850 to 2020 with
shades of blue showing cooler than
average years and red showing hotter
than average years the longanite station
is due for destruction this week
a new study has found that all of the
coral reefs in the western indian ocean
are vulnerable to collapse the area
accounts for up to five percent of the
world's coral reefs and covers more than
11 000 square kilometers supporting
vital marine life around madagascar and
the seychelles
well coral reef ecosystems are amongst
the most biodiverse and important
ecosystems but up to half of the world's
coral reefs are already degraded with 14
of the loss happening just in the last
decade
in the west indian ocean the reefs in
the waters around the masaren islands
southern and eastern madagascar and the
comoros islands are considered
critically endangered
with the rest of the reefs around
madagascar and the outer seychelles they
are endangered and that leaves the rest
of the reefs at the very least
vulnerable to collapse partially caused
by destructive fishing techniques and
warming ocean temperatures leading to
bleaching events
well joining me now from mombasa in
kenya is david abura who's author of the
west indian ocean report and founding
director of cordial east africa welcome
to you so all the coral reefs in the
western indian ocean at risk of collapse
so what are the implications of that not
just for biodiversity but also also for
people's livelihoods
well that's well that's that's right
anna so with the loss of coral reefs
there's our coastal zones depend a lot
on tourism and on fishing as well and on
trade and all of these are dependent on
coral reefs for their protection and the
products that they give the food that
they provide
and so the loss of the reefs will be a
real blow to the economies of all of the
countries in the region
so what could be done about it
well some of the re some of the threats
that we assess so overfishing can be
managed locally and need to be and
pollution is another threat we didn't we
weren't able to assess at this scale but
climate change is really the over
arching threat and that will only get
worse over the next few decades and so
that really needs the paris agreements
you know all the discussions we had at
cop26 to come to fruition and to really
uh
really take action and and and stop
carbon dioxide emissions
so some solutions at local level but do
you feel encouraged by some of the
political agreements made at cop226 but
also a cop 15 the biodiversity
conference as well
when i was at cop26 and i must say the
energy
there was tremendous both inside the
venue and outside and i think the
political agreements are always somewhat
less uh than many people would like but
that's the nature of politics but
they really show these cops really show
the commitment of governments scientists
cities of the public to really take
action the awareness is growing and so
both the the awareness that is brought
through cop26 and that that will come
through cop 15 on biodiversity we're
hoping that these will really turn the
tide on the action that is needed within
the next 10 years
to to avoid our coral reefs from
becoming from collapsing in the next few
decades
david thanks very much indeed
thank you
now every household in wales is to be
offered a free tree to plant as part of
a scheme to tackle climate change the 2
million pound scheme will allow people
to plant the trees themselves or have
one planted on their behalf by the
woodland trust more than 20 community
hubs will open across wales for
residents to collect their trees next
year
and in the rush to plant millions of
trees to help develop biodiversity and
mitigate against the effects of climate
change hundreds of thousands of plastic
tree guards are used every year now
they're necessary to protect new trees
as they grow but they're often forgotten
about after use and end up as litter
well let's hear now from mike appleton
from the yorkshire dales millennium
trust who's working to change that
[Music]
so this year we're aiming to remove 40
000
guards from the from the landscape
working with partners like like tubex to
make sure that they're recycled
correctly
i think for us it's important that it's
uh
to note that there's a community effort
to renew guards
we will bring a group out from kind of
an urban area of leeds or blackburn or
bradford and actually come out and spend
the day spend the day in the dales you
know asylum seekers and refugees who you
have to kind of get away from the
stresses that are alive
we've got one that's uh that sheep's
wool which uh you know everybody
especially in the girls big farming
getting quite excited about we've got a
couple of
classes we've got traditional um
cardboard tubes as well in various
heights
compostable
plastics as well which need to be
composted at 50 degrees centigrade
[Music]
do stay tuned coming up after the break
i'll be joined by the economist vicky
price and the climate columnist for the
independent donaka mccarthy and we're
going to be talking transition fuels and
whether we can look forward to flying
off on our holidays on hydrogen-powered
planes
hello and welcome back to the daily
climate show on sky news and we're
getting straight to discussing the
climate issues of the day now with
economist vicki price and climate
columnist for the independent donor
mccarthy so very good evening to both of
you nice to see you both
so first of all the uk government has
come under fire for promising to provide
more than a billion dollars of funding
to a liquefied natural gas project in
mozambique a group of climate scientists
say providing that funding is
incompatible with climate targets and
that undermines the uk's global
leadership on climate change but the
government argues the gas has a vital
role to play in a clean energy
transition so vicky first of all what do
you think about the uk
continuing to support
projects like this abroad we'll talk
abroad first before we talk domestically
do you think it's a good idea
well this particular one of course if
you think about the liquefied natural
gas it's quite useful has been very
useful in the uk recently has been
useful in europe and it will be quite
useful in asia where it's meant to be
going from mozambique because of course
when you look at what's happening with
coal fire power stations and coal
um produce considerably more and in fact
produce something like 45 more than uh
gas so gas as a transition
um product if you like is in fact very
useful particularly for developing
countries where the investment that
would need to be made otherwise is
beyond their means
right now okay so what do you make
you're well you're shaking your head
donnica do you not agree with that then
well to be investing billions globally
in new fossil fuels when we've got nine
years to get to net zero is is insanity
the recent research in the in the
journal nature said we need to leave 60
60 of existing gas in the ground if
we're going to have just a 50
chance of not breaching 1.5 degrees
centigrade so the britain should be
doing is investing in enabling
developing countries go to directly to
renewables rather than making them
dependent on new fossil fuel investment
and we have to remember the investment
in mozambique it's a tiny fraction of
what britain's investing globally it's
just not 0.1
over the next 10 years british banks
government and oil companies are
proposing to invest
750 billion in new fossil fuels
including glass it's untenable
what about domestically then vicky i
know that shell talked last week about
the the need for continued investment in
oil and gas they say it's critical to
the country's energy security
what about the uk
i think up to a point that's true uh but
of course what needs to happen is it
should go hand in hand with carbon
capture and storage and i think that's
the development that we need to see
happening i know it's been talked about
for quite some time so far it hasn't
been developed to scale but i think it
can and the right investment will make
quite a big difference there so for the
time being i think the transition period
is such that if we don't have enough
security of supply here we will see the
the types of increases in prices we've
seen very recently and which of course
will turn the consumers you know off the
whole idea of climate change if it's not
done properly so yes i think some
balance uh in the development is
absolutely essential but i don't
disagree that we need to get to the
right end uh you know when we look at
what is required in terms of climate
change measures both mitigation and also
adaptation and donor the uk government
says there's likely to be an ongoing but
diminishing demand for oil and gas that
the uk couldn't commit to phasing out
the energy sources entirely for now do
you think that's a fair position
um
nobody's talking about phasing out um
oil and gas immediately what we're
talking about is a transition over maybe
a decade what we are talking about is
stop investing in new fossil fuels we
have more than enough gas to to burn the
planet with more than enough oil so
investing
five trillion dollars over the next 10
years in new fossil fuels which the
government is supporting through the
through our banks etc it doesn't make
any sense so that's the situation we
have to do is stop the new investments
in fossil fuels and actually invest
the 5 trillion in renewables for both uk
and foreign developing countries okay
let's move on to our next subject shall
we because earlier in the show we heard
how hydrogen-powered planes
could make flying more sustainable now
hydrogen doesn't produce any co2
emissions its only waste product is
water so could this be the start of
guilt-free flying i mean vicki
everyone's going to like the sound of
that so what do you make of this project
to try to develop a liquid hydrogen fuel
aircraft
well if it were to work that would be
absolutely brilliant uh it's been talked
about for some time but the interesting
thing is that the airline sector that
accounts for something like two percent
of global co2 emissions are present but
rising has already managed to improve
its efficiency very significantly but i
think that would make a huge difference
i mean we know that it isn't going to
solve the problem completely in terms of
aviation because there are lots of other
things that come out in the atmosphere
when you fly at high altitudes but it
will certainly make a big big difference
because basically the co2 would no
longer be emitted it would just the
waste would be water but if you're able
to do long distance and have the right
aircraft that is able to support it then
obviously will make a tremendous
difference in terms of how we can
envisage the future in a clean sort of
net zero environment which hydrogen i
think can do and there are expectations
that it might actually by 2050 supply
something like 25 to 35 percent of all
energy needs
delica how optimistic are you
i think there is an extraordinary press
release by the government if you read
the detail in it it says if the
technological uh barriers which they say
are big are breached then they may
produce a plane by the 2030s or 2040s
what's going to happen to aviation
during the 20s and 30s as we emit a huge
huge amount of fossil fuels and the
second issue both of you have mentioned
water as a byproduct of hydrogen planes
50 of the global warming emissions from
planes currently come from water vapor
it heats the planet so what we will do
with this plane is we'll reduce the
carbon emissions by 50 percent and
double
double the the eva the the water vapor
emission so we end up with the same
amount of global warming this is
nonsense we need to do what the
government needs to do to tackle the
vast amount of people who are rich who
are flying unnecessarily four percent of
the global population fly abroad each
year we need to tackle the frequent
flyers with a tax and reduce that
wasteful carbon emissions very briefly
respond to that vicky
the water vapor aside just the fact that
short-term people need to fly less and
there's a huge proportion of people that
don't fly at all what about the others
well
the truth is of course that flying has
brought lots of lots of countries
together and has encouraged growth and
remember that flying isn't just for the
pleasure of people it actually carries a
lot of freight so what's been happening
recently in particular given that we had
problems bringing anything by sea is
that airplanes have substituted if you
like moved in to to take off that load
and and ensure that the supply chain
works so you shouldn't look at flying as
just something that people who can
afford it can do monica very you've got
10 seconds you're shaking ahead
yeah replacing um shipping with air
freight is probably quadrupling the
carbon emissions from that transport if
not more it's not it's completely
unsustainable to be switching to
airplanes for freight okay we clearly
need to revisit this subject another
time but donald mccarthy vicky price
good to get your thoughts tonight thank
you
and that's everything from us for today
on tomorrow's show we'll be joined by
simon lewis professor of global change
science and ucl and the environmental
campaigner baroness brownie-worthington